[Music]
we teamed up with busy and Michaels for
some creative holiday gifting tips my
goal is to put the gift Kevin gave
Michelle and me to shame really Kevin
Frazier no thank you really not a gift
can I give it back of course a Michaels
gift card is perfect for anyone but
today I chose to go with the more
homemade feel I want it to be like
luxuriously ridiculous over-the-top yeah
it would be cute because he's a Kevin
and I Mykelti if I can find like a quick
K they're festive can I use these
expensive okay are they expensive
I'm neither for you okay how bad I'm
thinking you are a very crafty person
this sort of feels like the mothership
of like where you would come for
inspiration some of my earliest memories
are going to Michaels with my mom on the
kid picking out crafts it really has
been a part of my life and I have in
turn done that with my girls I think
when it's done Louise the only thing we
honestly it's really good
should we show it I don't know should we
- we show yes okay ready one two three